hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta emisión nos acompaña a
arcadio del valle estamos hablando de
una persona que hace estallar todos los
estereotipos estéticos en un universo en
el que precisamente la imagen es un
factor clave y hablamos del mundo de la
moda a 10 modelo de talla grande y su
irrupción en la industria de la moda
pulveriza los límites tradicionales y
también los cánones físicos de todo este
universo adi del valle muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24 no muchas
gracias por tenerme ahí bueno en los
últimos tiempos han aparecido varios
súper modelos no que han roto con
estereotipos sobre las tallas pero tu
casa es bastante singular y por varios
motivos no digamos por tu personalidad
artística que se destacan o repleta de
glamour por tu estética cambiante hay
digamos una atracción absoluta hacia vos
atrapas todas las miradas
sentís que tu presencia en la industria
de la moda ayuda a redefinir por ejemplo
quién puede ser modelo de que contribuye
a desestigmatizar de alguna manera la
diversidad corporal
exacto yo creo que nos ven mucho mucho
aunque en los huevos los últimos años ha
habido modelos como los contienda
barreras que no se les tipificó cuerpo o
talla y yo está modelando ya casi como 5
años
el person de hoy sin grey después como
si fuera un tabú como quiera porque como
no hay nadie haciendo o tratando hacer
lo que yo tengo como modelo y ser
representación en la industria de los
fashion pero en diferentes partes de la
industria en la industria del jury en
muchas partes o eso es una pasión mía
estatal de escape escoge el espacio de
esos lugares que nunca lo estaban hechos
para la gente que parece lo que parece
como yo absolutamente hay un momento que
quizás fue clave bueno bueno lo contarás
a continuación causaste una suerte de
revolución cuando comenzaste a publicar
fotos mostrándote - cubierto no sin
camiseta en la playa por ejemplo
sentiste que hiciste un quiebre clave y
por qué crees que llegaron justo en ese
momento tantas miradas cuando exponía su
cuerpo
yo creo porque como
especialmente como los hombres nosotros
tenemos 7 en seguridad de lo que todo el
mundo tiene su inseguridad pero los
hombres siempre tienen un extender que
yo no pueden ser bolera bol nou no por
no poder y no amar su cuerpo como es
porque en la sociedad se ve como muy muy
blandito o muy femenino pero como yo en
ese día no mostrarme como yo soy el
cuerpo conmigo con menos ropa como la
playa a una piscina eso parece que me
dio como un clic como que la gente que
parece como a mí puede vivir la vida
como la otra gente que son más delgada
como yo hoy pero pueden existir en
lugares así y es algo simple pero es una
inseguridad grande que mucha gente tiene
y yo creo que ahí empezó no no nada más
yo modelando pero un movimiento como de
aceptar el cuerpo de uno como ves no
importa el tamaño del cuerpo y
esta parte de hacer y no mostrar ha
ayudado a mucha gente porque vengan dar
me manda mensaje todos los días o cada
rato con lo poco fotos así es como
inspiración para mucha gente poder ver a
alguien como yo existir y no mostrarme
así absolutamente ahora a ti tu cuerpo
tu imagen y también en tu actitud no
sólo desafían lo que son los
estereotipos en el mundo de la moda
también estás defendiendo una identidad
el eje de teno qué sucede con la
aceptación de los cuerpos xl en el
colectivo lgtb
como en muchas comunidades siempre como
nosotros como que somos más grandes
siempre somos como cuando tengo un juego
el gordito siempre es el último que cogí
no no lo miran para cosas pero no
piensan que los otros somos válidos
y no podemos y somos wardi de también y
no existir también en nuestras
comunidades y en la comunidad de energía
lgp
pero de que yo empecé esta carrera a la
comunidad de gente que ha sido bien amb
walking conmigo especialmente la gente
que está en la industria que son
representan el eje ham ellos me han
mostrado mucho amor y me están a mi lado
eso ha ayudado a la comunidad de gente
como yo en mí y no en esa comunidad que
vino como válido y también y no queremos
ser ama y no amado y tal vez con nuestra
comunidad soy yo creo que existiendo en
esos espacios en diferentes comunidades
porque yo represento todo tanta gente
como yo soy ha sido como un objeto bien
positivo para abrirnos poder hacer parte
de eso absolutamente ahora también
circula cierto prejuicio negativo no
muchas veces se asocia el sobrepeso a la
insalubridad a los malos hábitos hay
muchísimas personas que incluso atacan
al activismo de las personas con
sobrepeso y señalan que se está
difundiendo a una vida no saludable por
decirlo de alguna manera te ha ocurrido
esto y que respondes a ese tipo de
discursos ahí sí
todo el tiempo la gente demanda vino a
alguna mente te dan complementos pero de
misma vez te tiran pero tú estás
promoviendo obesidad o una web de vida
que no es saludable pero te que ha
empezado especialmente con esta parte de
mi carrera de excel y no positivo con yo
mismo para poder ayudar a la gente que
sé que están en mi lugar que se parecen
como yo pero que no se parecen como lo
que éste de seguridad
la meta es no vivir no es de dieta ni de
ti que está medio tu cuerpo y yo
promoviendo un estilo de vida porque yo
nunca ha promovido el estilo de vida que
es al houthi o no es saludable
el propósito ni del mensaje siempre es
que lo que yo pongan las redes sociales
o el trabajo que yo haga y ponga en el
no en el universo que la gente puedan
ver que ellos pueden hacer todo existir
y amar su cuerpo como es en este momento
no importa decir son grandes libros de
tanta talla grande como yo o talla
pequeña le importa actitud para existir
y no en el cuerpo que tú está ahora y si
tú quieres regalar tu cuerpo que tiene
seguridad que quiere cambiar eso está
bien también pero mí y mi mensaje
siempre que que la gente se puedan
armarse en cada etapa que tenía su vida
y para mucha gente eso es difícil y eso
algo que mucha gente
en su vida es tan inútil ingresé a mi
país importante hacer un mensaje
positivo que uno se puede amar no
importa en qué condición y que está
mayor a este mensaje siempre
absolutamente muy lindo mensaje sea de
mashad y crees que está cambiando algo
concretamente en el mundo de la moda
dijo sobre todo para las personas que
antes no se podían identificar con
modelos por cuestiones de etnia de
cuerpo etcétera hay cambios concretos
y por mi lado yo estoy tratando de hacer
esa diferencia por lo mucho más en los
últimos dos años con los trabajos que me
están apareciendo hasta acá hasta el son
de hoy como trabajo que están pareciendo
ahora diga mente emitiendo en la
industria de la belleza también no se ve
gente que parece como yo en esa nobleza
en ese sector de la industria y 1 am soy
yo creo que hay cambio para mí
cambio por está sucediendo poco a poco y
para mí es importante tener esa
conversación con esos pues a compañías
que me contratan para no ser no no no me
contrate alguien mira a mí nada más por
este momento porque sigan haciéndolo
porque y no en diferentes partes de la
industria hace falta mucha
representación de todos los cuerpos de
toda la identificación aunque la gente
si quieren ver es una revista y puedan y
no ver algo y ellos saben y lo mismo
mira a mí o lo que sea otro modelo que
parece que lo está haciendo y aprende
presentando y para mí son importantes y
ese es el mejor regalo que yo puedo
recibir al que la gente pueda verse en
especialmente la moda que en un espacio
que siempre ha sido para cuerpo delgado
sino para nosotros y además sos el
fundador del latin great y verdad
contanos en qué consiste este proyecto
si el line screeners de soy yo ese
concepto me vino como un año y medio
atrás a algunas amigas griegas son
modelos plas también y estaban viendo
esta tía dije a mi vida miente y ley
nosotros debemos yo quiero hacer como
una plataforma que yo pueda a hailey
diferentes latinos de la industria mía
el don pero no solamente la mía
creativos en la comunidad latino que uno
no puede usar mi plataforma que una
plataforma grande pero yo sé que mi voz
es grande y si yo puedo hacer y
compartir esta plataforma para para
darle luz a otro creativos pues eso me
vino la gente y yo empecé con unos
amigos unas amigas y amigos míos y simón
foros y
y les los entrevisté todo individual
para ellos del sur y su parte de lo que
ellos comandan en la comunidad
team book los recogió para un artículo y
desde ese momento esa plataforma ha
crecido y ahora estamos un 'break' pero
hay proyecto que yo he hecho ya unos
meses ataque vagas a él para seguir
creciendo esa plataforma que va a seguir
dándole luz a diferentes creativos
modelo docente en la comunidad latina
que están en la industria que no no
tienen mucha voz para poder expresarse y
e ir hoy darle luz a gente diferente que
lo son siempre lo mismo ahí nos queda
aproximadamente un minuto pero quisiera
preguntarte qué pasa afuera de las
pasarelas no en la vida cotidiana
pero qué pasa afuera de las pasarelas no
de este ambiente del que hablábamos
donde la imagen es tan importante que
pasa pero no cómo vive la vida cotidiana
a una persona a plus 6
este es normal de los otros no es para
la vida ni es normal como cualquier
persona y yo me levanto igual como otra
persona y mi vida es difícil con un tan
cierto espacio navegar siendo alguien
como yo pero yo creo que yo aprendo
tanto y sin rector sólo a la misma vez
yo aprendo mucho cómo navegar y como
cultural
relaciones con gente la industria que me
quieren ayudar y me quiere empujar para
seguir adelante representando a la gente
dios que parecen como a mí y puedan y no
relacionarse con alguien que se parezca
como yo lo hace muchísimas gracias por
brindarnos este tiempo a france24 ha
sido un placer dialogar contigo
igualmente muchas gracias pero no
gracias a ti en esta audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]